Here's what gives me hope for humanity.
I believe that we can change
our human nature for the better.
This chance is unique.
It's where we stand in history right now.
No other generation
has stood here before us.
Homo sapiens has been around
for about 300,000 years.
Other humanoid life forms
have come and gone.
We find their traces.
We search for their stories.
But we are the success story.
We've survived natural disasters,
famines, floods, earthquakes, plagues,
woolly mammoths,
mess-ups of our own making.
We're smart, no question.
The question is: Are we smart enough
to survive how smart we are?
It's not looking so good just now, is it?
(Laughter)
We stand facing the possibility
of global conflict.
If that happens,
it will be our Third World War
in not much more than 100 years.
If Putin's violence stops today,
the problem doesn't go away.
As across the globe
dictatorism threatens democracy.
I wonder whether as a species
we can survive any of this,
even if those threats disappear.
Those living inside the snow globe
of their magical thinking
will not be insulated
against the facts of climate breakdown.
And yet, still, we go on
heating up the planet.
Still we go on polluting the earth.
Still we despoil
our precious natural resources.
250 years ago, we kick-started
the Industrial Revolution.
The machine age.
It's when we first hear the buzzwords
of the modern moment.
Disruption, acceleration.
That's Karl Marx, actually.
Acceleration of production,
the factory system,
acceleration of transport,
the coming of the railways.
No need for ships to wait for the wind.
Coal-fired, steam-powered.
Acceleration of information.
The global village.
And it's when we start
digging fossil fuels out of the ground
in planet-changing quantities,
when we start pushing carbon dioxide
into the atmosphere.
In a salami slice of space-time,
human beings have changed the way
that we live on the planet forever.
We've moved out of
the agricultural economies
of our evolutionary inheritance
into the industrial economies and beyond
of where we are now.
There's no one else for us to turn to.
There's no one else for us to blame.
There is no us and them.
There's only us.
So will we continue to be
the success story of the known universe,
or are we writing our own obituary?
The suicide species?
Now I was raised
in an evangelical household.
We lived in end time.
We were waiting for things to get so bad
that Jesus would come back and save us.
The apocalypse.
It's what the prepper communities are,
well, prepping for.
And it's why super rich white guys
are buying up tracts of land,
hoping that they can live inside
a kind of wi-fi-enabled Noah's Ark.
(Laughter)
Well, we can have the end time
if we want it.
We know those stories from our religions,
our sci-fi, our movies.
We are uniquely placed
to bring on the apocalypse.
And we're uniquely placed
to save ourselves, too.
If we could accept that as a species,
Homo sapiens needs to evolve further.
And that's what gives me hope,
because we have the means
to evolve further.
And that's AI.
Now look, I don't mean
the geeks will inherit the earth.
I'm sorry, geeks. You won't.
(Laughter)
I don’t really want to talk about narrow-
goal artificial intelligence at all.
That term of John McCarthy’s,
“artificial intelligence,”
is it any use to us now?
I'd rather call it
alternative intelligence.
And I think humankind is in need
of some alternative intelligence.
In 1965, Jack Good
talked about AI as our last invention.
He meant superintelligence,
the kind of thing that worries
Bill Gates and Elon Musk.
You know, the "Terminator" scenario.
The final us and them.
But I think that's all to do
with our doomster mindset.
We don't have to vote for the apocalypse.
Jack Good worked at Bletchley Park
with Alan Turing during World War II,
building the early computing machinery
that would crack the Nazi Enigma code.
Now after the war, Turing,
wrestling with the problems
of a stored, programmed computer
had a bigger dream on his mind.
And in 1950, Alan Turing published a paper
called “Computing Machinery
and Intelligence.”
And in there, there's a chapter
that's titled "Lady Lovelace's Objection"
where Turing time-travels back 100 years
to have a conversation
with that long-dead genius,
Ada Lovelace, the first person to write
mathematical programs for the computer
not yet built by her friend
Charles Babbage.
Now Ada wrote that as well as
doing awesome stuff with numbers,
the computer would,
if correctly programmed,
be able to write novels and compose music.
That is a pretty big insight in 1843.
"But," said Ada, "The computer
should never have any pretensions
to originate anything."
She meant, think creatively.
Well, Ada's father was Lord Byron,
England's most famous poet,
and England is the land of Shakespeare.
More poets.
And Ada had seen Charles Babbage's kit
all over the floor,
and she wasn’t having some steampunk,
coal-fired nuts, bolts, bezels, levers,
gears, cogs and chains,
crank-handled machine writing poetry.
"Well," said Alan Turing,
"Was Lady Lovelace, correct?
Could a computer ever be said
to originate anything?
And what would be the difference
between computing intelligence
and human intelligence?"
Well, I'll tell you one difference,
and it's optimistic.
Computing power uses binary,
but computing intelligence is nonbinary.
It's humans who are obsessed
with false binaries.
Male, female. Masculine, feminine.
Black, white. Human, non-human.
Us, them.
AI has no skin color.
AI has no race, no gender,
no faith in a sky God.
AI is not interested
in men being superior to women,
in white folks being smarter
than people of color.
Straight, gay, gay, trans
are not separating categories for AI.
AI does not distinguish
between success and failure
by gold bars, yachts and Ferraris.
AI is not motivated by fame and fortune.
If we develop alternative intelligence,
it will be Buddhist in its non-needs.
(Applause)
Now I am aware that the algorithms
ubiquitous in everyday life
are racist, sexist,
gendered, trivializing,
stoke division, amplify bias.
But what is this teaching us
about ourselves?
AI is a tool.
We are the ones who are using the tool.
Hatred and contempt, money and power
are human agendas, not AI agendas.
We've been forced
to recognize the paucity,
the inadequacy of our data sets.
And humans are trained on data sets too.
We've had to recognized
the unacknowledged ideologies
that we live by every day.
Rationality, neutrality,
logic, objective decision-making.
What can we say about any of that
when we see what we are
reflected back to us
in the small screen?
And it's not a pretty sight.
AI is not yet self-aware.
But we are becoming more self-aware
as we work with AI
and we realize that Homo sapiens
is no longer fit for purpose.
We need a reboot.
So what are we going to choose?
Apocalypse or an alternative?
I believe that humans
have a strong future as a hybrid species
as we start to merge
with the biotechnology we're creating,
whether that's nanobots
in the bloodstream,
monitoring our vital systems,
whether it's genetic editing,
whether it's 3D printing
of bespoke body parts,
whether it’s neural implants
that will connect us directly to the web
and to one another,
insourcing information,
enhancing our cognitive capacities.
And if we manage to upload consciousness,
I think that the shift
from the transhuman to the posthuman world
will seem natural,
an evolutionary necessity.
Why do I say that?
I say that because for millennia,
all human beings have been obsessed
with the big question,
the absurdity of death.
We asked, "Do we have souls?"
We watched the spirit
wait to leave the body.
We created the world's first
disruptive startup, the afterlife.
(Laughter)
Now a multinational company,
with a vast VR real estate portfolio.
A mansion in the sky,
sir?
Our earliest extant written narrative,
The Epic of Gilgamesh,
is a journey to discover
if there is life after death.
And what is life after death?
It is the extension of the self
beyond biological limits.
Now I’m a writer, and I wonder,
have we been telling the story backwards?
Did we know we would always get here,
capable of creating
the kind of superintelligence
that we said created us?
We're told were made in God's image.
God is immortal.
God is not a biological entity.
Since the 17th century, the Enlightenment,
science and religion have parted company.
And science said, all that God thinking,
the afterlife stuff,
it's folly, It's ignorance,
it's superstition.
Suppose it was intuition.
Suppose it was the only way
we could talk about what we knew,
a fundamental, deep truth
that this is not the last word.
This is not the end of the story.
That we are not time-bound creatures
caught in our bodies.
That there is further to go.
I'm fascinated that computing,
science and religion,
like parallel lines that do meet in space,
are now asking the same question:
Is consciousness obliged to materiality?
Now ...
I accept that machine intelligence
will challenge human intelligence.
But the mythos of the world
is built around a group of stories
that showcase an encounter
between a human and a nonhuman entity.
Think of Jacob wrestling the angel.
Think of Prometheus
bringing fire down from the gods.
In these encounters,
both parties are changed,
not always for the better.
But it generally works out.
We've been thinking
about this stuff forever.
It's time that we created it.
And we could have some fun stuff too.
Who wants their own AI angel?
Me.
There's a message in a bottle
about this 200 years ago.
When Ada Lovelace was busy getting born,
her father, Lord Byron,
was on holiday on Lake Geneva
with his friend, the poet Percy Shelley,
and Shelley's wife, Mary Shelley.
On a wet weekend with no internet
Byron said --
(Laughter)
"Let's write horror stories."
You know what happened.
Out of that came the world's
most famous monster, Frankenstein.
This is 1816, the start
of the Industrial Revolution.
Mary Shelley is just 19 years old.
In that novel, there is
an alternative intelligence
made out of the body parts
from the graveyard and electricity.
An astonishing vision
because electricity
was not in any practical use at all
and was hardly understood as a force.
You know what happens.
The monster is not named. Not educated.
Is outcast by his panicky creator,
Victor Frankenstein.
And the whole thing ends
in a chase across the Arctic ice
towards a Götterdämmerung
of death and destruction.
The death wish that human beings
are so drawn to,
perhaps because it's easier
to give up than to carry on.
Well, we're the first generation
who can read Mary Shelley's novel
in the right way,
as a flare flung across time,
because we too could create
an alternative intelligence,
not out of the body parts
from the graveyard using electricity,
but out of zeros and ones of code.
And how is this going to end?
Utopia or dystopia?
It's up to us.
Endings are not set in stone.
We change the story
because we are the story.
Now, Marvin Minsky
called alternative intelligence
our "mind children."
Could we as proud parents accept
that the new generation
that we will create
will be smarter than we are?
And could we accept
that the new generation we create
need not be on a substrate made of meat?
Thank you.
(Applause)
Thank you very much. Thank you.
Thank you.
Helen Walters: Jeanette, stay right there.
I have some questions.
Jeanette Winterson:
I know you want your lunch. Me too.
(Laughter)
HW: No. Everybody, stop.
OK. That was amazing. Thank you.
What would you say
our odds were of survival?
JW: Look --
(Laughter)
I'm an optimist.
I’m a glass-half-full girl.
So I know that we’re running out of time,
time is the most precious
resource we have,
and there isn't much of it.
If we get this right soon,
it can really work.
If we get it wrong, will be fighting
each other with sticks and stones
for scraps of food and water
on an overheated planet
in the ruins of dictator-world.
But --
(Laughter)
OK. But we could get it right.
That’s why I feel
we’ve arrived at this moment before,
and it might disappear
back into space-time.
Then we'll have to wait billions of years
to get here again, which is so dull.
So let's not fuck it up.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
HW: I've got another question.
I just wanted to have
a moment of eye to eye.
Don't fuck it up. Don't fuck it up. OK.
JW: That’s the message.
The whole TED Talk is: “Don’t fuck it up.”
HW: But wait, I have another question.
JW: I could have saved
12 minutes, 55 seconds.
HW: Yeah, well, I'll just be
the title that we put online.
Jeanette Winterson: “Don’t fuck it up.”
OK. I want to talk about love.
So in your memoir,
which everybody should read,
it is called “Why Be Happy
When You Can Be Normal?”
The very end of that book is about --
it’s a good title -- t’s about love.
And you write, "Love, the difficult word.
Where everything starts,
where we always return.
Love. Love's lack.
The possibility of love."
Now I don't want
to bastardize Ada Lovelace.
She was all about originating.
But what about love?
What about alternative
intelligence and love?
JW: We'll teach it.
HW: We’ll teach it?
JW: Yeah. And listen, any of you who ever
fell in love with your teddy bear,
which is all of you, know what it's like
to have an intense relationship
with a nonbiological lifeform.
(Laughter)
HW: Jeanette Winterson, I love you.
JW: Thank you.
HW: Thank you so much. Thank you.